here we are on the 17th of march
and just a year ago
march 18 2020 one
year ago tomorrow i stood before you
to express my deepest concerns about
completely shutting down our beloved las
vegas
its hotels its businesses and its
schools
the decision by one individual which
required
no vote by the nevada legislature or any
other
elected body promised to cause
undue hardship to hundreds of thousands
of nevadans my plea at the time
was to take a more nuanced approach
to enact safety precautions that
would enable las vegas to continue to
function
a full year later we see some states
which took this moderate approach like
more populous
florida and texas for example
actually real realized a lower
death count per hundred thousand than
did some states with prolonged total
shutdowns
like michigan new york and nevada
and that's according to statista.com
march 8 2021
nevadans many of whom still have not
been able to get through to the state's
unemployment office to receive funds
owed to them suffered tremendously
many of our small businesses and even
some of our larger ones were forced to
close up
to shutter their doors and our children
have suffered immeasurably
as i pleaded for moderation some
individuals
especially some certain newscasters
took great issue with my stance to enact
reasonable safety precautions and
entrust
nevadans and tourists to make
responsible decisions
i'd like to recall what i did say on
march 18
just a year ago in response to the
governor's shutdown directive
and i quote this exactly
it has been my intent as the mayor of
this great city of las vegas
that we would be able to remain open for
business
even when realizing that there could
have been
constraints put upon us to which we
would have
reasonably adhered because
not only do i understand but also
because i'm
painfully aware and sensitive to the
very many who live
paycheck to paycheck i know we
and they cannot survive any total
shutdown of the economy
for any length of time beyond the
immediate week or two
so many working in hospital in the
hospitality industry
more likely in big hotels but also
those mom-and-pops small privately owned
businesses
these are most definitely at the
greatest
risk they cannot survive any lengthy
shutdown
and thus my full-out efforts will be
focused on keeping as many of
our people as possible employed
and asking our governor to
shorten the projected shutdown
and quote that was
a year ago here we are
a full year later our businesses are
still
only operating at 50 percent capacity
up from a bizarre 35 percent
that was effective until three days ago
some have not yet been permitted to open
at all our children are now
only returning part-time
to public school in a hybrid model
and then only kindergarten through fifth
in person
full-time on april 6th
tens of thousands of students have
missed out on graduation
proms extracurriculars sports
scholarship
not to mention a year's worth of
invaluable in-person instruction
in march 2020 when the governor
announced
in a quote and this is a quote a
courtesy call
that he was shutting the schools down i
pleaded with him
to implement safety measures and
mandatory temperature checks
instead for all entering the buildings
i was harshly told he was not seeking
any input
there is a mantra in some circle that
these draconians shut down
saved lives and while
any one death is beyond heartbreaking
the data shows no consistent
no consistent correlation in
death rates between states with
prolonged complete
shutdowns like nevada and those
that adopted more moderate safety
precautions
in fact the four states with the highest
death rates
were the states that adopted stringent
shutdown policies
one must also ask if masks
and social distancing are sufficient
now to slowing the spread of this
virus would that not have been
sufficient a full year ago
what is the rationale for continuing
even at 50 capacity
with other precautions like mass
mandates in place
in addition to increasing vaccinations
america is the land of the free but
americans in some states not all have
been forced to subjugate their freedoms
to the will of a single individual
seemingly in perpetuity there is
no apparent sunset on
emergency powers bestowed to some
governors
which smacks of tyranny
i am now calling for a return
to personal responsibility and personal
liberty those who do not want
to or choose to go out in public pace
places are not forced to do so
just as those who do not want the
vaccine
are not forced to take them
those who want to wear a mask or two or
three of them
are not prevented from wearing them
masks distancing frequent hand washing
and sanitation
are reasonable measures that health
officials assure
us truly make a difference
that is following the science
the science has not proven that
completely shutting down accomplished
anything more than moderate reasonable
precautions nevadans and americans are
smart enough to understand what's at
stake
and make appropriate choices for
themselves and their families
as one caller to my office recently
expressed
it is beyond sad and concerning
to see lady liberty on our las vegas
strip
wearing a mask it is the antithesis
of what she and america represent
personal freedom i said this a full year
ago tomorrow and i repeat it again
today the city of las vegas will seek
ways for
people and businesses to advocate for
their own lives
make their own choices create and follow
their
own destinies and live being assured
they have the right to do so in dignity
earning a livelihood providing for their
families and even helping others
to enjoy those same rights and dignities
upon these american founding
principles we will continue
to stand thank you my dear council
persons